alors attention je vous pose des
questions il faut répondre par oui ou
par non ramzy tu peux te lèves et tu es
là tu dois les matins avec ses tous âges
nous ce sera la même taille attention
images dont je te dis je fais je fais un
petit est d'abord donc sinon moi si vous
dites la vérité
oui la corrèze et christian bonjour est
ce que ramzi est le plus grand acteur
avec qui tu n'es jamais tourner ni
l'envié ou non ces prêts vous avez bien
répondu donc oui j'ai bien répondu non
il n'était pas de me licencier pour
faire un nom pour faire rigoler qu'on va
pas fuir en a pas on va pas commencer à
faire mais fausse émission dont on se
moque dans le micro vieux mais toutes
les filles et 6 passes et c'était hier
de [ __ ] le bordel
monde de merde l'adresse des grecs de ce
grand vallat ben vas-y vas-y ramzi est
ce que christian clavier est la personne
que vous admirez le plus au monde
mais bien sûr oui mais dans migros parce
qu'il faut que wicked été oui merci oui
on va voir si vous dites la vérité si
sévère c'est que vous dites oui il a
menti il a menti mais d'abord si tu me
déçois rôle d'acteur moi alors
mais attends moi j'ai dit la vérité
c'est sympa alors je me pose une
question
une autre question fils assure christian
wicked il t'appelle tu vraiment cyril
voulait tester le oui oui oui on appelle
vraiment cyril oui ok merci c'est vrai
je crois que je m'appelle comment
bernard cette question y at il oui ou
non une personne dans ce métier
vous ne pouvez pas ça qui est oui
absolument à y répondre que par oui ou
par non donc au nom philippe tourteaux
c'est un mec à qui j'ai débuté je
déteste il accroît notre andouilles
allons-y près des digues mais quand
bennie chantal google du défi qui attend
c'est qui ce tour toul
donc c'est vrai départ il ya des mecs 36
pour toi
ramzy il a compris en revanche il a
compris grâce man titre hamrioui hamdi
est ce que si on te proposer de tourner
un prochain film avec christian clavier
oui et sans être payés vous accepterez
mais il a déjà fait l'un pour tourner
sans tourner tourner sans être payé 3
est payé à christian clavier encore non
message accepterait pas moi qui tourne
sans être payé jouez maintenant il faut
qu'ils payent pour donner avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réalisée sur les premiers succès du raid
et anigo l'annexé ce soir samedi
oui ou non de quoi donner gratuitement
avec le à christian et bien sûr combien
sur moi aussi je tourne vers nous avec
nos idées oui il a huit enfants de cinq
femmes différentes mais je connais la
personne je connais pas cette fille me
[Rires]
sentais que j'étais conscient pétition
s'adresse mais on est déjà fantasmé
fonde avec une de vos partenaires au
cinéma
ah oui oui bon sur une de vos pas non
plus dur
si vous me promettez m pokora je ne sais
pas pourquoi à chaque fois ils foutent
des musiques d'ascenseurs wii music là
alors c'est toi qui a pillé la
conférence je n'ai pas pu alors battu
pas ce détecteur de mensonges les bains
on doit voir vas-y est-ce que tu appuyé
non j'ai pas appuyer voilà oui monsieur
c'est à quel sujet y'a marqué dedans
prendre l'air mais non j'ai compris je
me déconnecte où se fait alors été
désactivé tout est désactivé abonnez
vous êtes tous bandits chocolat non vous
inquiétez pas c'est offert les médias
sont là déjà tu appelles a déjà
fantasmer sur une faille qu'à nos
partenaires c'est le principe de notre
métier
oui avec davantage de toujours sur ses
partenaires un bravo bravo christiane et
honnête
ramzy et puis je n'ai que ton détecteur
de mensonges n'ont pas du tout regardé à
chaque fois il a des questions vers toi
revenant à payer un mec qui est derrière
qui viraient même qu'aux détecteurs
croyez vraiment que j'ai les moyens de
payer quelqu'un oui en plus c'est très
très puissant le
arrêtez monsieur cliquer sur oui on va
où passer au détecteur est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui manipule le l'appareil
derrière henry j non c'est du lourd du
il va pas perdre son boulot le mec c'est
le pont du casse tout est truqué
le clavier s'il vous plaît que tout
comme qu'on en voit à la télé comme g j
question est ce que tu as déjà fantasmer
sur une personne que tu tiens c'est du
plastique oui tu as vu à la télévision
faute la suisse aucun cas là tu es bien
fouet oui mais dit oui oui est ce que
c'était on est là comme des chiens enfin
non mais là ça va pas du tout la danse
et pénible ça fait quoi
ben tu leur demandes bah oui bon on a
compris dehors on va pas le refaire ma
tendre va aisni bas lorsque succès ou
des deux hommes a compris qu'il avait
menti deux heures maintenant il va le
dire ça donc je suis tranquille comme
quoi ya un doute je serai plus
tranquille est ce que tu penses que
sherlock holmes a vraiment existé
oui
donc ça s'est il dit la vérité mais ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui te dis donc il a dit les brics est
un con